هذه ليست المره الاولى التي ندخل فيها الى
جبهه باخمر لكن الوضع يختلف كليا هذه
المره ويمكنك ان تسمع القصف الذي يعلو
صوته كل ما اقتربت من مناطق القتال قصف
بجميع انواع الاسلحه المتوفره للطرفين اما
الدخول فقد كان صعبا نسبه لعوره الطرق
وسوء الاحوال الجويه
هذه الجبهه صعبه جدا هنا يجري قتال شرس
العدو يهاجم بشكل مستمر ونحن نعمل على
ايقافه ما كان عليهم ان يبداوا هذه الحرب
الارواح ولكن بالعوده الى سؤالك هناك قتله
والاعداد تتفاوت من منطقه الى اخرى لكن لا
استطيع ان اخبرك باعداد القتلى بخصوص
السلاح نحتاج الى مزيد من الاسلحه ونتمنى
ان تكون متطوره وبشكل عام نحن في اهبه
الاستعداد ونضرب جنودنا على مستوى العالي
حتى لا نسمح للعدو باحت اراضينا هذه تغطيه
حصريه لقناتي العربيه هو الحدث من خنادق
الجيش الاوكراني المطله مباشره على منطقه
تواجد القوات الروسيه هذه تسمى الجبهه صفر
الى هذا المكان ستكون امنا العدو على خط
التماس وانت هنا ستكون في امان في الداخل
وتحتميه من قصر المدفعيه والرصاص العربيه
والحدث حصريا في خنادق الجيش الاوكراني في
مواقع الجيش الاوكراني في جبهه الاخوه
الجبهه الاعنف الاشرف
تشاهدون اطلاق النار بين القوات
الاوكرانيه والقوات الروسيه لا يتوقف هذه
الجبهه هي الاكثر اشتعالا في الصراع
الروسي الاوكراني يمكنك سماع ايضا اطلاق
النار من جهه القوات الروسيه وكما تشاهدون
الجيش الاوكراني ايضا يقوم بالرد على
اطلاق النار من الجهاز الاخرى نحن الان
نشاهد بث مباشر عن طريق الكاميرا التي تم
وضعها هنا في هذه المنطقه طبعا هذه
المنطقه التمركز القوات الاوكرانيه وخنادق
الجيش الاوكراني القوات الروسيه تبعد في
هذا الاتجاه حوالي 500 متر فقط من هذا
المكان الذي نحن فيه عن طريق هذه الكاميرا
عن طريق البث المباشر الان يستطيع الجنود
هنا ان يراقبوا تحركات القوات الروسيه
الان نحن نشاهد بث مباشر لمواقع تمركز
الجيش الروسي في هذا الاتجاه حوالي 500
متر وابعد نقطه قد تكون حوالي 800 من هذا
الاتجاه
الفيديو
من داخل الخندق حركه القوات الروسيه من
خلف التل ومناطق تمركز الاليات والمعدات
الروسيه نحن نرى الان المنطقه التي
يتمركزون فيها اذا راعينا حركتهم في هذا
الاتجاه فهذه علامه هجوم نحونا هذا هو
الخندق الاخير في مناطق تمركز القوات
الاوكرانيه في جبهه باخوت في اتجاه
القوات الروسيه تبعد من هنا حوالي 500 متر
فقط تتحركوا جبهه القتال في جبهه باخوت
وهي جبهه عريضه في هذا الاتجاه او ذاك حسب
قدره اي من القوتين الروسيه والاكرانيه
على اجبار الاخرى على الانسحابي او التخلي
عن موقعها هذه الخنادق التي نحن فيها الان
وهي مناطق تمركز الجيش الاخراني عن ساعتها
وقامت بحفرها وكانت تتمركز فيها القوات
الروسيه الى القوات الاوكرانيه في عمليه
هجوم مضاد استطاعت ان تسيطر عليها لتصبح
مواقع اوكرانيه لقناتي العربيه والحدث
الذي فعادل
من خلال الجيش الاوكراني